[Música]
[Aplausos]
no deja de ser paradójico hablar de
pobreza en este edificio tan
espectacular
curiosamente cuando voy creciendo y voy
conociendo el lugares me doy cuenta que
donde más se habla de pobreza es en esos
lugares donde no se le conoce
en la pobreza no hablamos de pobreza
vivimos hablando de qué haríamos si
tuviéramos un montón de plata
y cuando éramos chicas
con mi hermana si había algo que
soñábamos
era poder ser ricas para poder comer
todos los días
hamburguesas era lo único que deseábamos
era con lo que soñábamos todos los días
muchas veces íbamos al centro
caminábamos hasta un lugar de
reconocidas hamburguesas
y buscábamos sin que los empleados se
den cuenta
si alguien había dejado burguesa fuego
fritas lo que sea rogábamos
todos los días que alguien hubiera
dejado una hamburguesa casi completa que
alguien la hubiera probado dijera no me
gustó y nosotros llegaremos justo en ese
momento soñábamos con ese día
papas fritas siempre hay la gente
siempre deja algunos
ocurrió
un día
si vamos a ese lugar
y había en una mesa una hamburguesa casi
por la mitad y la otra apenas había sido
probada había papas fritas completos y
lo único que se habían llevado esas
personas que sobre ellos fueron a comer
y se arrepintieron fue la bebida
o sea que teníamos comida
prácticamente sentirá el menos
prácticamente original para nosotros
nos sentimos como se debe haber sentido
el coyote cuando atrapó el correcaminos
era haber encontrado eso que siempre
soñábamos
y empezamos a comer
estaba todo increíble y en ese momento
se acerca una empleada en general en
esos locales suelen ser muy atentas
y nos de se nos preguntaba todo bien
y mi hermana que es una persona muy
particular
le dice todo bien pero la hamburguesa
estaba fría
mi empleada se va no nos dice nada
éramos chicas chicas chicas
a los 5 minutos o 10 vuelve la empleada
con un menú completo para cada una
de hamburguesas papas fritas y gaseosas
o sea íbamos a comer de vuelta
hamburguesas calentitas y vamos a comer
de vuelta papas fritas calentitas y
encima nos habían traído gaseosas
y ahí ya nos sentimos como se debe
haberse sentido jesús cuando multiplicó
los panes y transformó el agua en vino
fue una felicidad espiritual
y yo creo que nunca más voy a comer en
mi vida
algo tan rico algo que me haga tan feliz
como me hizo feliz comer esas
hamburguesas que nos comimos dos casi
cada una
estoy un poquito nerviosa pero mi nombre
es my de arena
y hablo hasta el cansancio de pobreza
y soy muy insistente con una cosa es que
pobreza y marginalidad no son lo mismo
es algo que repito hasta el cansancio la
pobreza
hablamos todos la conocemos todos hay
formas de medirla hay gente que la mide
que sube que baja pero de la
marginalidad muy poco se habla y muy
poco se sabe
muy poco es lo que hemos logrado cambiar
acerca de la marginalidad
y a mí me gusta mucho hablar de eso
porque lo poco que sé no lo sé como
estudiantes de ciencias políticas que
soy sino que lo hace por mi vieja
y como toda persona o como muchas
personas me cuesta hablar de mi vieja y
por eso es que tengo esta ayudita acá mi
vieja nació y creció en la marginalidad
el que nace en la marginalidad como mi
vieja tiene todas las de perder ya de
entrada
mi vieja nació pesando un kilo y medio
sabía no sabía que tenía
que iba a tener menos posibilidades que
todos
por los alimentos que recibió no solo
desarrollo menos capacidades cognitivas
sino que además tiene menos defensas en
forma más fácil o sea que el que nace en
la marginalidad no solo va a tener menos
herramientas para desenvolverse sino que
además tiene menos esperanza de vida
yo durante muchos años
no entendí a mi vieja que tenía mucha
bronca
no entendía cómo
alguien puede vivir sin un proyecto no
entendía cómo alguien puede preocuparse
solo por lo que tiene que comer ese día
pero gracias a la educación que adquirí
en la escuela pública y en la
universidad entendí que la marginalidad
es una tragedia
y cualquiera que vive una tragedia
no puede ponerse a pensar en planes
específicos o en determinadas metas
cualquiera que vive una tragedia lo
único que puede hacer es limitarse a
intentar sobrevivir
y eso es lo que hizo mi vieja
eso es lo que hace mi hija que intenta
sobrevivir eso es lo que hace cualquiera
que vive en la marginalidad
intenta sobrevivir y nada más
nosotras gracias de nuevo a la educación
que adquirimos pudimos además de soñar
con la comida de las hamburguesas soñar
con un proyecto
y creo que esa fue la diferencia más
grande entre nosotras sin mi vieja haber
tenido la posibilidad
de soñar con ese proyecto
les quiero pedir
que se imaginen en serio ahora
esta noche viene un terremoto
que viene un tornado o un alud o lo que
sea y quiero que se lo imaginen de
verdad
quiero que se imaginen qué es lo que más
les dolería perder
y quiero que se imaginen quién es la
primera persona a la que llamarían para
ver si está bien
y tienes la primera persona la que
llamarían
para pedirle ayuda
me gustaría que pensemos
cómo reaccionaría la gente si nosotros
tuviéramos una tragedia y perdida en
emea perdiéramos todo
estoy seguro de que sería denominado en
una tragedia seríamos nosotros las
víctimas de la tragedia
y mucha gente se solidarice se
solidarizaría con nosotros
nos ayudaría a recuperar ese nivel de
vida que hemos perdido
sin embargo para que la gente se
solidarice con vos y para que recuperes
algo primero tenés que haberle obtenido
nadie se solidariza o muy pocos con
aquellos que directamente nacieron sin
nada
cuando les pido que se imaginen eso es
para que después de esta charla
entendamos que si es una tragedia para
darlo todo también es una tragedia en
hacer sin nada
si es una tragedia imaginarnos perder
nuestra computadora con nuestros objetos
también es una tragedia que haya tipos
con carros que pasen y vivan de la
basura
y yo quiero después de esta charla
que se vayan pensando primero que ya no
es invisible ni la pobreza ni la
marginalidad
y segundo pensando en esto que les digo
de que las tragedias visibles las
palpables tienen fecha tienen lugar nos
marcan como sociedad hay fechas para
recordarlos hay lugares que los
recuerdan
hasta tienen canciones muchas veces que
se les dedica a las víctimas caídas en
ellas pero nadie tiene una fecha de
cuando arrancó la marginalidad nadie
tiene
un aniversario de cuando arrancó nadie
le lleva flores
a los que viven esta tragedia y nadie
conmemora a los que se mueren de hambre
o se mueren de frío por los que se
mueren de enfermedades que en otras
circunstancias hubieran sido
perfectamente curables
pero lo que más me gustaría y para
terminar bueno puedo más
es que pensemos y vamos a seguir
sentados sin ver esta tragedia que está
ocurriendo
si vamos a seguir en estado de shock
como si fuéramos nosotros los que
vivieron la tragedia o si vamos a
reaccionar con aquellos que la padecen
y si vamos a actuar como nos gustaría
actuasen con nosotros si vivimos una
tragedia
lo que más me gustaría es que empecemos
a hacer algo
para que ningún pibe tenga que soñar con
comida y que empiece a soñar con su
proyecto de vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]